fear to me means absolutely nothing
anymore fear played such a big piece of
my life and it controlled me to not do
what was best for me so fear to me now
is nothing but an imagination
[Music]
my name is flip Rodriguez I'm a
Hollywood stuntman and on American Ninja
Warrior in the ages of 9 to 15 I was
sexually abused by my father like how do
I live my life after that like I can't
trust anybody I got into parkour and
freerunning when I was the age of 19
Park when freerunning are two different
definitions are very similar parkour is
just straight forward vaulting jumping
over walls over any obstacle in your way
rerunning is your own style your own
flippin flow of it make it nice and
pretty as possible and you take your
time when I first got started I've never
been upside down so my body's like wait
whoa we don't do that and then the fear
aspect hits in so it's like let's stop
and think about this is this really
worth getting hurt fear is what stopped
me from trying to stop my sexual abuse
parkour and freerunning has been a
stepping stone for me to heal and be
okay with my sexual abuse it's because
fear is a big part of parkour and
freerunning so every day I trained I was
always encountering a new fear I started
in America Ninja Warrior season 3
and then on season seven actually
explain my story I was sexually abused
after my interview came out I've had
kids write to me one of the parents
reached out to me turns out that the
daughter and the son were being sexually
abused by a family friend the child sure
started breaking down crying she was
like what flip is talking about is also
happy to me and they brought up charges
the gentleman got convicted of that and
that right there blew my mind away
because not only did I heal myself but I
also saved somebody from further abuse
and that was incredible I like to give
back to the community with using my
story I coach Parkman free running I'm
not teaching him just about parkour free
running I try to teach them tools of
life you guys just saw me kind of felt a
little bit what do you got to say okay
every single person can relate to fear
yeah so if I can teach these kids from a
young age to separate fear from danger
that is a life tool my negative piece of
my life I can now turn it around and put
a spotlight on it in the sense of this
is who I am this is what happened to me
and look at me I'm still shining
you